are there any dogs
a normal day for an animal control
officer i'm not sure if there is such a
thing but
they'll come in and they'll talk to
janice who's our admin
administrator and she will hand them if
they've got any inspections that need to
be done during the day so
when they do inspections it's in
relation to menacing dogs
so we have to go and do a property
inspection for those so
they'll get handed some jobs to do and
then they may have
paperwork left over from the day before
or they need to catch up on some work
but then as soon as that phone rings and
a call comes in for perhaps
for example a wandering dog they have to
go out and try and find this dog
so they'll if they pick up the dog and
they can't find the owner that's
close by then they need to take the dog
to the pound
and they'll process that so they
sometimes can take 10 15 20 minutes
to process the dog and try and find the
owner and then they'll leave there and
they may have another call that they
they have to go to or they'll come back
to the office and tidy up the paperwork
for that
and it just it's never the same because
the that
you don't know that the calls that
you're going to go to they might be
completely different
if they do have some down time then
they'll go and do
um some patrols perhaps through queens
park or go and visit the dog park
on ellis road which is always a favorite
thing of these today because i get to
actually catch up with owners
who are happy to see them and it's just
a good chance to catch up with people on
the street just to see what
the issues are if there are any
animal control officers are human they
they do they enjoy their job
but sometimes these aspects of it that
they don't enjoy and it's usually
relating to people who aren't doing what
they should be doing
they're not the big mean gruff guys
going and picking up
dogs just because they enjoy it and they
enjoy putting them in the pound and
just depriving owners and families of
their dogs
nobody enjoys doing that part of it but
i guess the message is
there's a job that needs to be done and
these are the guys and girls that are
out there doing it
and give them a bit of a break if you
see them
taking your dog because there's a reason
behind it they don't just go and
swipe dogs off people's places because
they they feel like it
there's a reason behind it every dog and
has
an obligation to make sure that the dog
is registered and they look after their
dog and it's kept
controlled and confined so that's the
animal control officer's job to make
sure that everybody's actually doing
that
a lot of times when we go out there and
just deal with people in that they just
think we're offices and we're only there
just
yeah doing a job but we're actually got
our own dogs and our own pets
um and we love our dogs and we know
where they're coming from when it comes
to
having their dogs no it's it's yeah i
mean i've got dogs
other officers she's got a pig you know
and so we get out there and
try to do our best and help people out
that's good
it's really interesting it's not just in
the office all day you have
many different call outs to wandering
dogs and
maybe a dog bite or but then we have
nice call-outs as well and you go out
and
meet new people and come to the dog park
and
there's a good and a bad side to the job
you deal with a lot of
people that are quite abusive but then
you deal with a lot of people that love
their dogs and really care about them
they come from all walks of life and
they're actually a really good team to
work with
really knowledgeable about stuff and
really good with the
with the dogs mainly they deal with dogs
some of the situations that they find
themselves and i don't know if i could
could do that um
you know there's some quite nasty dogs
out there and they're having to
basically go in when everybody's running
away from
from these dogs and they do do a really
really good job because
i know lots of people you know wouldn't
be able to do it
but they also have to have some sort of
interpersonal skills as well because a
lot of the time they are dealing with
people
out on the street so um and when you're
taking somebody's dog they're
usually not happy about it and they do a
really good job with defusing situations
sometimes we do have to call the police
in for assistance but um that's
that's just part of the job as well
because you know if they're getting
abused and assaulted nobody should have
to put up with that
out on the street so there are certain
dangers to the job
and the guys are aware of that they're
fully kitted up with um
stab resistant body armor things like
that they've got
battens for the dogs and spray for the
dogs and things like that so
we don't let them just go out and walk
in the street and they shoot sleeves and
and away you go
but um yeah they're experienced and they
do a really good job
uh biggest challenge is probably the
public you know dealing with dog owners
i mean their
their dogs are their pets that's their
family so they do get a bit angry at
times but
yeah and we do get angry dogs as well
but yeah they seem to be easier to
handle than some of the people we've got
to deal with
and um he just told us to go away in a
just kind of manner but
not so appropriate but yeah so we're
just going to warrant and get the police
and take the dog away if he won't
cooperate
ninety-five percent of them are real god
to deal with and um yeah sometimes they
get a bit just
you know get a bit angry themselves
because with their dogs biking and that
and you know they don't want their
dog to be in any trouble or anything but
usually they settle down pretty good and
then they come around and
that's good yeah they respect us for
what we do it's
just their job and they realise that so
moving forward for the council in terms
of educating owners
what we're actually hoping to do is get
into the primary schools and start
actually teaching kids about dog safety
awareness and things like that we have a
couple of packages that we're looking at
and we'd really really like to introduce
that into the school so we're actually
doing this the more proactive stuff with
the kids rather than just the reactive
obviously we still need to do the
reactive stuff but
um we'd really like to start getting to
the positive and proactive and
in educating the kids and if we educate
the kids then nine times out of ten it
goes back into the families
and um without probably even realizing
that the kids are teaching the parents
you know the right and wrong thing to do
with dogs and things like that because
i know it's a very um it's an emotive
subject it's very topical at the moment
about dog attacks
and i don't think there's any wrong time
to teach a child what to do if they're
approached by a dog or things like that
so that's
we're really hoping to be able to get in
to do that because we've got some very
talented people that can help us with
that
really we we're just doing our job and
we do care about animals there's a lot
of people think we don't
um we do care about animals and our jobs
just
yeah trying to help people out really i
mean if we can get a dog home to someone
we do
whether or not it costs them fees or not
be there to cost 95
get out of the pound and be run over so
we're only just trying to do a job guys
you